[Music]
one of the most remarkable aspects of
the human brain is its ability to
recognize patterns and describe them
among the hardest patterns we've tried
to understand is the concept of
turbulent flow in fluid dynamics the
German physicist Verner Heisenberg said
when I meet God I am going to ask him
two questions why relativity and wide
turbulence I really believe he will have
an answer for the first as difficult as
turbulence is to understand
mathematically we can use art to depict
the way it looks in June 1889 Vincent
van Gogh painted the view just before
sunrise from the window of his room at
the st. paul de ma soul asylum in sant
remedial vas where he admitted himself
after mutilating his own ear in a
psychotic episode in the starry night
his circular brush strokes create a
night sky filled with swirling clouds
and eddies of stars van Gogh and other
Impressionists represented light in a
different way than their predecessors
seeming to capture its motion for
instance across sun-dappled waters or
here in starlight that twinkles and
melts through milky waves of blue night
sky the effect is caused by luminance
the intensity of the light in the colors
on the canvas the more primitive part of
our visual cortex which sees light
contrast and motion but not color will
blend two differently colored areas
together if they have the same luminance
but our brains primate subdivision will
see the contrasting colors without
blending with these two interpretations
happening at once the light in many
Impressionists works seems to pulse
flicker and radiate oddly that's how
this and other impressionist works use
quickly executed prominent brushstrokes
to capture something strikingly real
about how light moves 60 years later
Russian mathematician Andrey Kolmogorov
furthered our mathematical understanding
of turbulence when he proposed that
energy in a turbulent fluid at length
are varies in
Horsham to the 5/3 power of our
experimental measurements show
Kolmogorov was remarkably close to the
way turbulent flow works although a
complete description of turbulence
remains one of the unsolved problems in
physics a turbulent flow is self-similar
if there is an energy cascade in other
words big eddies transfer their energy
to smaller Eddie's which do likewise at
other scales examples of this include
Jupiter's Great Red Spot cloud
formations and interstellar dust
particles in 2004 using the Hubble Space
Telescope scientists saw the eddies of a
distant cloud of dust and gas around a
star and it reminded them of van gogh's
starry night this motivated scientists
from Mexico Spain and England to study
the luminance in Van Gogh's paintings in
detail they discovered that there is a
distinct pattern of turbulent fluid
structures close to Como gaurav's
equation hidden in many of Van Gogh's
paintings
the researchers digitized the paintings
and measured how brightness varies
between any two pixels from the curves
measured for pixel separations
they concluded that paintings from Van
Gogh's periods of psychotic agitation
behave remarkably similar to fluid
turbulence his self-portrait with a pipe
from a calmer period in Van Gogh's life
showed no sign of this correspondence
and neither did other artists work that
seemed equally turbulent at first glance
like MOOCs The Scream while it's too
easy to say van Gogh's turbulent genius
enabled him to depict turbulence it's
also far too difficult to accurately
Express the rousing beauty of the fact
that in a period of intense suffering
van Gogh was somehow able to perceive
and represent one of the most supremely
difficult concepts nature has ever
brought before mankind and to unite his
unique mind's eye with the deepest
mysteries of movement fluid and light
[Music]